بعد مرور ثلاث سنوات على تعامل العالم مع
جائع كورونا يعلن المسؤولون في الصين
مجددا تمسكهم بسياسه صفر كورونا رغم
تاثيرها على الحياه اليوميه واعاقتها لنمو
الاقتصادي
بكين تتمسك بسياسه صفر كوفيت الشامله رغم
زياده الاصابات المستورده من الخارج
لجنه الصحه
ورده على انتقادات داخليه وخارجيه حول
سياسه الصين في التعامل مع كورونا اكدت
انها لم تتلقى اي تعليمات بعد لتخفيض
القيود الصحيه في البلاد المفروضه منذ
وان الصين لا تزال تسجل اصابات جديده
بكورونا بلغت اكثر من ثلاثه الاف و600
حاله كما رصدت الفرق الصحيه جديده للوباء
شمال شرقي البلاد قرب الحدود مع روسيا
وكوريا الشماليه
وفرضت الحكومه تدابير اغلاق لمده اسبوع
على 600,000 شخص يعيشون قرب مصنع لهواتف
ايفون بعد فراري موظفين منه لتفادي الحجر
الصحي
ويرى خبراء في الصحه الدوليه ان الصين
ربما ستبقي على القيود الصحيه لعام اخر
وتواصل الاختبارات الصحيه وسط مخاوف من
تفشي فيروسات خارجيه خاصه ان الانباء
تتحدث عن انتشار ثلاثه فيروسات في
الولايات المتحده وكذلك الحال في دول
اوروبيه بينها فرنسا التي تشهد تفشيا
واسعا لالتهاب القصبات الهوائيه جاسم محسن
العربيه